who wears that horn going off here that
is it in the back just give it a little
double-check go out there with a
baseball bat tell him to shut the [ __ ]
up but like walk towards his walk out
there with your dick in your hand that
way you startle anyone you see and you
always have the first move Yeah right
here yeah you gonna use a kombucha
bottle yeah but as the healthiest
appears you've done this twice really
yeah we've done this in the podcast
before great for sure I like the fact
that you're willing to do that too
I don't think we can show it on YouTube
though so we'll have to have to move
away up all right guys stick out great
too cuz there's a big opening yeah so it
doesn't vacuum up how often DP do you
piece everything you like one of them
healthy water drinker dudes I pee a lot
do you are you a healthy water drinker
dude interesting detail this just
happened oh you ran out hold on a second
we go to the recycler get me something
it's alright I'm pitching I got a strong
grip memories you can move it to take it
a cop not a bottle seems like oh man
it's going back in though I can feel it
starting to swell back in that's that's
not healthy I'm pitch I've been pitching
too long should I pee into the cup a
bottle yeah oh you athlete it oh thanks
man
oh yeah a lot went back into my urethra
Ari Shaffir couldn't hold in his pee
ladies and gentleman couldn't means
wooden filled up one kombucha bottle
here's a cap there fella
and then filled it up again I had to go
empty it out for him thanks for doing
that
pleasure front yeah I didn't want to
leave you hanging there dude
[Music]